[Music]
tomorrow Las Vegas marks five years
since the one October shooting and there
are events planned all weekend and
starts tonight on the Vegas strong
resiliency Center is urging you to take
part in a lantern ceremony it honors
victims survivors First Responders I'm
Kenneth Charles joining us now live from
the healing Garden this is just a
beautiful tradition Candace good morning
good morning Heather it really is and 2
000 people have already registered for
this event really speaking to how
everyone has been touched by this
horrific tragedy and how they all want
to come together and honor and really
celebrate the lives they're lost because
really that's what we want to do is
remember that these folks were brothers
sisters friends people that will be
remembered forever and you can simply do
so by joining into the Lancer ceremony
even though they have run out of kits
you can make your own we're going to
make one for you now I'm joined by
Jackie Harris who is a mental health
provider and who will be walking people
through this process tell me a little
bit about how this helps people heal
thank you I I think one of the ways that
this helps people heal is they can
personalize this so we're gonna take a
minute to show you a lantern and people
can write their own messages I know when
I did my own Lantern I even printed out
some pictures not so great of an artist
and I put things on there like Vegas
strong and a butterfly which really
represents healing and growth and I put
some relaxing music and I just found
myself in a very peaceful place even
doing this you know myself and the other
thing that's amazing is that we've uh
you know delivered kits all over the
country and even in different parts of
the world so no matter where somebody is
at they can participate in this activity
we have small groups of folks that are
going to get together in their home
we're in an outdoor space and they can
really focus on the healing and the hope
that we hope this activity brings now
you guys will be doing this at United
Way of Nevada at six you're going to
show me really quickly how it's done
absolutely it seems like as it really is
simple folks yeah you can just put these
four sticks in correct yes we have these
four pillars and as we go through the
activity which you can also find online
line even after the event at the Vegas
strong resiliency Center
we're going to kind of go through and
and talk about what these pillars can
represent for folks and of course you
can decorate this the kit comes with
some markers and some stencils or you
can get your own supplies they're easy
to find these Lantern kits online you
can just slip this over the pillars
after it's decorated and you can put we
like kind of the battery operated
candles it's safer yes absolutely well
it really is absolutely beautiful and it
really is simple to make Jackie thank
you so much for helping us and showing
us how to do this and again this all
kicks off at United Way so Nevada at six
of course there'll be a broadcast a
special broadcast of this on the Vegas
strong resiliency Center YouTube at 6
30. we'll have all those details for you
of course on 8newsnow.com for now live
from the healing Guardian I'm Candace
Charles 8 News Now